♪♪
Narrator: DR. RHYS MORGAN IS AT
THE ROYAL NAVY SUBMARINE MUSEUM
IN GOSPORT, ENGLAND,
UNCOVERING INFORMATION
ABOUT A SECRET WEAPON
FROM THE REVOLUTIONARY WAR.
AND THIS IS IT -- THE TURTLE --
THE FIRST SUBMERSIBLE USED
IN RECORDED UNDERWATER COMBAT.
♪♪
BUSHNELL'S PLAN FOR THE TURTLE
WAS TO SNEAK UP ON
THE BRITISH ENEMY SHIPS
MOORED IN NEW YORK HARBOR.
THE VESSEL HAD LOTS
OF WEIGHTS IN IT
TO HELP IT SINK INTO THE WATER,
AND UNDERNEATH THE BASE,
THERE WAS A BALLAST TANK,
WHICH WOULD BE FILLED
WITH WATER.
AND THE OPERATOR,
A MAN CALLED EZRA LEE,
WOULD PUMP THE WATER
IN AND OUT OF THE TANK
TO HELP SINK TO THE RIGHT DEPTH.
Narrator:
AS THE TURTLE SLIPS UNDERWATER,
ITS TWO SURFACE-MOUNTED
SNORKELS SEAL.
THE PILOT POWERS THE CRAFT
USING A HAND-CRANKED
FRONT-MOUNTED PROPELLER.
AS HE APPROACHES HIS TARGET,
HE READIES THE TURTLE'S WEAPON.
THE TURTLE'S WEAPON,
A KEG OF GUNPOWDER,
WAS ATTACHED TO THE BACK
OF THE WOODEN HULL.
AS THE SUBMARINE SILENTLY
CREPT UP UNDERWATER
TO THE BASE OF THE SHIPS,
IT WOULD BE ATTACHED
BY THIS DRILL,
WHICH WOULD BE LITERALLY
HAND-DRILLED
INTO THE BASE OF THE SHIP.
Narrator: UNFORTUNATELY
FOR THE PILOT, EZRA LEE,
THE BRITISH FLEET
HAD METAL HULLS.
BY SHEER BAD LUCK,
EZRA LEE WASN'T ABLE
TO DRILL INTO THE SHIP'S HULL,
SO THE TURTLE WAS A BIT
OF A FAILURE.
BUT HAVING SAID THAT,
IT DID SET THE PRECEDENT
FOR SUBMERSIBLE COMBAT,
AND THE PRINCIPLES
OF BALLAST TANKS AND PROPULSION
STILL, TO THIS DAY,
REMAIN ON ALL SUBMARINES.